babes guess what october 1st me and sal
are co-headlining the lyric in baltimore
october 29th we're co-headlining durham
north carolina at the dooring performing
arts center you can go to
christiecomedy.com or salvatocomedy.com
and get those tickets also happening
right now i will be at the borgata in
atlantic city on january 29th go to
christiecomedy.com click the link for
january 29th the borgata use the
pre-sale code chaos the pre-sale is
happening right now it is over tonight
pre-seal code chaos borgata january 29th
october 1st at the lyric baltimore with
sally babes october 29th in durham with
salad vapes january 29th to bragato with
chrissy d what do you got to lose
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
is
baby
h-e-y-b-a-b-e
this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e the [ __ ] is
h-e-y-b-a-e-v-e
cell volcano everybody
i'm chris stuff for now
god damn it we got pillows
i didn't have a beer
i have no beer
oh this guy's got me a beer give it up
for this guy
thank you a pbr
there he is the homeless pimp everybody
everybody
he's homeless
and he stands there begging for money
hello did you guys get your shirts
yes you've been asking for merch we
finally got it who was here for the
first show
you guys were here in the first show
well i don't know if that was all of you
or one woman who could scream really
loud
who was here from the first show
[Music]
okay welcome back are you coming to
wednesday's show
no
guess what we're doing for tomorrow's
show we're going to give somebody the
couch
and we're going to uh people didn't care
they were like ah
yeah we thought it would be cool we're
like we'll sign it we just ordered it
just for today
so it's a new couch plus it's in the
episode plus we'll sign it plus he
probably will fart into it all night
shout out broccoli
give it up for seoul joel richardson
everybody
absolutely
look at him we used to call him we used
to call him the kung fu panda but now
he's lost a lot of weight so he's the
keto panda
but he's still a panda and he likes
women over 65 years old
i'm just kidding joel he put up a tent
in the middle of a sand pit in royston
pennsylvania and it is the first live
hey babe show and i wouldn't have had it
any other way this is the first night
at some point during the show
truthfully a full locomotive will come
through i'm not lying to you this used
to be the tunnel he just turned it this
way yes
and when that happens when the
locomotive comes we will all stop and
sing in unison the shit's bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e okay we'll do that
there you go thank you the first show
was a rousing success it was rousing it
was uh 99 degrees yeah
it's a little cooler now 98 degrees
nicolas give me just one night
is that una no che you said 98 degrees
and then you don't back me up on their
number one single
wait a second wait a second what 98
degrees are they they sing what's that's
not their una noche it's not their
biggest song it's not what oh the
invisible man
what's 98 degrees biggest song not buena
noche wait hold on you didn't back me up
and then 400 people didn't back you up
because of you because of you i could
walk in the sidewalk no that's kelly
clarkson
we
oh i do
cherish you from the depths of my soul
is that real beyond my control i've
waited so long are you singing this say
this to you
if you're asking do i love you this much
you just sound like a goat well baby uh
dude
i don't know that one right
i guess
i don't fly with me come fly come fly
away
we were thinking about what song to come
out to and they were like just the
bananas easy that's our song right now
the collection why are we still friends
i we almost came out to uh immigrant
song
singing the hey babe in the immigrant
song have you guys anybody zeppelin fans
oh so that would work i was gonna go
hey
right nice we didn't know if you guys
would get it so you could sing
i like it dude full of estrogen yeah
you brought these pillows from the
actual i broke them from home from the
stool
i left a true story i left the house i
was in my lobby i said [ __ ] the pillows
and i went back up the pillows my
sneaker tongue says hey babe right there
oh wow hey babe custy wants these what
how did you get custody of these i
didn't get them i got well we're going
to get them for you wow who's giving you
custom secrets shout out lucia footwear
shout out shout out to footwear company
on instagram they made me sneakers they
put a hey babe on the left tongue with
my daughter's name delilah and then on
the right one they put my other podcast
to chrissy chaos podcast with my newborn
daughter's name violet on the bench
awesome what's the name of the place
it's lucia footwear company of footwear
uh if you're listening and we know you
are we know you are lucia footwear i'll
just go [ __ ] myself
sorry lucia footwear company
how you guys doing well i like it it's a
tuesday night i guess nobody has worked
tomorrow or we all degenerates what are
we doing
both a little bit of both
wow wow so you guys just you we even ask
it's not even like come see it says come
see us bring a chair
like you know what i mean like bring
your food bring yourself bring food
bring your snacks bring everything the
only thing you don't have to bring is a
vaccine card
round of applause how many people here
have had how many people survivors here
nice
wow
at least one of you have it right now
and this is a super spreader event
it's just the stats folks yeah we didn't
do we even do like the like the gun with
that like the temperature and stuff
no someone could definitely have it no
no it's one of those things where it's
uh
i think you know there's no way here's
the thing geographically we're we're
within one mile of a wawa so covet is
very high
it's spiking that's just what it is you
don't even know that you can order cova
um through the deli machine now right
now
and get a cover test yeah tell you right
now if one of you is bold enough to let
us know that you have covered right now
we'll give you the couch we'll sit on
the floor tomorrow night
yeah if you can prove to me right now
with the rapid test that you are
positive coveted yeah you can sit you
can you can have the couch
yeah
and i'll also catch you on the lips for
the patreon
wow
patreon coming soon
coming soon may never come off coven
right now
get out we were kidding this is a comedy
show we're doing comedy
pick up your stones
um imagine stoning somebody
hey babe let's start off with something
light stoning stoning let's talk about
stoning
yeah babe no i um i kind of feel like
i'm the i have a very big um
head almost uh people used to call me
chrissy crow magnum because of my head
it's a neanderthal head you'd have to
hit me with a piece of style i've been
handical styling
jesus when jesus finished you he turns
onto one i made this one the end of all
style yeah it's a neanderthal motif um i
have a i have an above average head and
a thick plated head that i think it'd be
um it'd be hard to kill me with just one
stone
yeah do you know that there's a culture
i don't know what the culture is and
this is not this is not funny but it is
it's ridiculous they put people
they bury you
like in a sandpit like in a pit like
yeah and just your head is out and then
they throw rocks at just your head
well that also is funny though it is
yeah it's not it's terrible for the
victim but it's it's it is oh that's no
that's terrible
it's not we're going to stand here we
have a willing participant how about
that whoever tells us they have coven
legally we bury you up to your neck
we're hitting the head with stones but
you get the couch but you get the couch
but exactly your decapitated body gets
the couch
what's considered a big head sound size
eight hat which guys what i have no yes
really yeah so you're considered a big
head by the internet i guarantee you
that hat doesn't fit my head right now
go ahead and it's a little loose on i
have a little loose
it actually fits perfectly well i will
tell you literally regret the spin
i will tell you what it does do it
really does accentuate the size of your
head yes yeah i didn't think you had a
big head you put that on and now i feel
like i need to make a
donation yeah
well used to go fund me you you look
i never see you in a hat
it's weird when you know someone so well
and then they do something that startles
you a little bit yeah it's i'm a huge
melon head let's see can you turn into
an you actually look younger you look
like a little punk kid with that on yeah
yeah like well i'm gonna i'm gonna be 37
years old on thursday wow
[Music]
how you feel
i feel
i feel my cholesterol my my numbers
could be better my cholesterol blood
pressure's a little high okay yeah but
that's all workable especially at your
age yeah but i don't know man the doctor
told me six months ago he said if by
your 37th birthday your cholesterol
hasn't gotten within normal range i'm
putting on medication and i want to tell
you my friend it is not within normal
range
but i also had a budded bagel from
dunkin donuts this morning so that's not
helping yeah what you just have to stop
doing is just stop eating straight
cholesterol yeah and it'll go away yeah
i i i said this on the last show but
just coming from philly i had i wrapped
a philly cheesesteak and a piece of
pizza on saturday and said this is
probably not good for my numbers yeah
did you think of your doctor when you
were chewing that thing he doesn't even
want to talk to me anymore my doctor he
doesn't want to talk to me i i took a
test i don't know why i put that back on
you what do you want to do that's
unclear by the way i got to be honest
with you
i would think because sweating so much
you know had that on all day would not
be your fault at all
almost no scent i would say actually
zero cent coming off the hat
oh it was it was it's gross
it was sweaty when you put it on just
now i'm sorry no no no was it no no no
no i'm not talking about sweat i'm
talking about this the smell you didn't
smell you're a scentless man you don't
have a scent yeah senseless of a woman i
am you're a scentless of a woman yeah i
i use a secret
have we talked about this designed for a
man made for women that's correct
designed for a woman made for an
anti-person
well anyway it's an antiperspirant and a
deodorant and i use shower fresh and it
really as you can see it works it works
but i don't put deodorant on my head you
don't put the odor on your head what
no i shampoo in my condition and i did
that right before coming here yeah do
you use deodorant what do you think of
this all the celebrities now they're not
washing their bodies so what do you
think that's about i don't know man i i
think it's a conspiracy because we think
we're running out of water
that's what i think's happened i think
as you guys would say wooder i think
we're running out of water is that what
you say here they say winter you guys
have a weird accent and guess what guess
what today's not tuesday it's tuesday
today's tuesday tuesday i always feel
like you want a huge
oh yeah yeah philly yeah
after the show you want to hang out you
want to get home
[Laughter]
i always hate my accent like when i go
anywhere and i'm outside of new york
especially overseas i always feel like i
don't have good addiction i always i
feel like i think they call it over
oceans
fyi oh yeah you're right
just asking
certainly there's not season between us
there's no i'm not what i'm going over
sea i mean you know what i mean anybody
i could swim across
the house i'm going over the ocean yeah
if i'm going overseas you know i mean i
do we even need a 747 right this season
going over oceans what's the closest sea
to us
the sea closest what's the closest sea
to
here that's the atlantic
the caspian sea
uh pimp what's the closest sea
to us oh you guys get to see how pimp
types and writes and spells yeah keep an
eye out for that it's a show in
itself
geneva on the lake is the closest beach
to pittsburgh pennsylvania good job pimp
which i'll be at october 2nd closest sea
to pa is the geneva on the lake beach in
pittsburgh
i was driving here and i saw a car on
the side of the road with the hood up
and smoke coming out and i was like i if
that happened to me
i'd be stuck i have no what's your level
of can you tinker around under a hood
can i take it your car broke down are
you in trouble are you calling hey are
you going to get out there with what i
would do what i would i guaran what i
would do is any time my car breaks down
i always just assume it needs fluid so i
swear to god if my car broke you
ejaculate onto it yes okay i would that
or i would just take the windshield
wiper fluid and just start pouring it on
the old engine and just say drink it
baby drink
people
people pull over like you need help now
i just need the fluids just need the
fluids by the way
you know
october 2nd i'm doing a show in
warrendale pennsylvania and the venue's
called gerbils
isn't that weird
do you want to set up for the jokers am
i on the is that my first episode of the
joker what was the place before it was a
comedy
buttholes i don't understand i don't
understand the gerbil thing
because people say richard gere anytime
you talk about richard gere they say put
a gerbil up his ass but i'm not saying
he didn't but i'm also
i want to understand why
he did that
we're not saying he did it richard
you're listening and we know that you
are we're not saying that you did it but
can you please call the hotline right
now and tell us why you did it i loved
you pretty woman which most people do i
loved even more in the mothman
prophecies
prophecy is one of the four movies i
walked out on in the theater you wanted
the movie i walked i said it you ready
for this you want to know the two movies
i walked out on in the theater in the
middle
their [ __ ] is bananas
h-t-y-b-a-v-e this [ __ ] is bananas
h-t-y-b-a-v-e this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-v get into it sir this [ __ ]
we have news to you the train goes by
for 15 minutes the [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e
this [ __ ] is bananas okay h
well they weren't joining
he wasn't in the white shirt he's too
cool for school you're front and center
you can't look at him
he showed up to the sandpit and
royceford with boat shoes on but there's
no seas next to us
what'd you think we're at geneva on the
lake in pittsburgh by gerbils what's
your name sir matt ryan
what's your name kevin derrick
james janine zach the worst one it could
have been zach
zach why are you such a horrible person
what do you love him
zack z sorry go ahead babe z a z a c h
or c ck ck get out
what z a k you [ __ ]
z
no k or h your name is zazz
z
what
that name doesn't exist
lis z i see you are a piece of [ __ ] you
son of a [ __ ]
you've never had your name on a t-shirt
or a license plate novelty license plate
or a keychain even
what
you have to knh off
oh
you cut off you all cut off the harry
like the zac zachary
z ac i know one thing and i know i know
one thing and i know i know one thing
for sure you storm the capital with a
name like that and and both shoes
there's no way the fbi isn't looking
because it's very easy you cac well
there's only one of them yeah
you can't have a you can't spell zack
zac and wear boat shoes it doesn't go
well you're you're coming here to be
punished
wait why did your parents make up a name
for you yes
why did you ever ask them like was it
just to be unique i'm now in a serious
i'm asking you
how to spell zach
put how to spell z-a-c and google will
just implode
they'll say they'll say are you
yeah
how to spell
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
variant spellings
z z-a-k-k sorry sorry
z-a-k-k is a [ __ ] boy yes it is and i
got news for you zach you are the new
variant you are yeah oh the z-a-c is
very very he's uh right in front make
put your man six feet six-foot perimeter
the two movies i walked out on yeah i
swear to god the stream i may even said
it on i may have even said it on hay bay
before in the middle cell in the middle
yeah and i'm sorry if i if i destroy if
i row and ruin the end [ __ ] boy right
here
vulgar slang a weak or countable man a
man who has many casual sexual partners
contemptible man yeah
a man who wait a man who has many casual
sexual i thought it was like an insult
that seems like uh
yeah it's like fuckboy has hatched their
goals
yeah
um
two movies i walked out are you ready
for this in the middle 100 swear to god
first one a beautiful mind with russell
crowe never saw it in the middle can i
tell that was an academy nominated movie
you ready for this i said this movie is
so effing boring i can't stand another
second of this movie it's so stupid it's
just a movie about a professor and all
he's doing is talking to his friends
about being a professor you find out 20
minutes to go before the end of the
movie that the people you talk to are on
his all in his head he's schizophrenic
no nobody in the movie is real the
second movie i walked out of right in
the middle of it the sixth sense
no
because i said what are you not i said
the movie's stupid what is bruce willis
some kind of pedophile all he's doing is
talking to the kid
wow i walked out of both of them and it
turned out at the end he i haven't seen
a while but he was a pedophile the whole
time right he was metaphor the whole
time bruce was pedophile the whole time
and was on found to be on epstein's
island
jacob pina's thumb
what whoa what is this oh my god
that thumb looks like zach was your
screen name in high school thumbzack
was the thumbzack
okay that his thumb is five and a half
inches well that's bigger than me in
most places
soft not hard hard i'm at five and a
half six foot warrant
beautiful mind yeah
jacob first discovered that his thumb
was unique when he was a teenager
despite how abnormal it is doctors
confirmed that it wasn't linked to any
underlying could you imagine that was a
what would that be a sign of if you got
a long thumb
is that i don't know
did the thumb end up there or was that
kid born like six pounds with a five and
a half inch thumb yeah
seriously they're like your baby would
be six pounds but he is eight pounds
yeah
oh my goodness wow i wonder if he uh
utilizes that to his advantage in any
way like a thumb in the ass or something
no
no
i just meant like you imagine in any way
but that yeah like like his
ex-girlfriend i'll never do thumb in the
ass again not after i got yet
oh he's on tick-tock of course why
wouldn't he be he is able to dislocate
it and extend it
i just dislocate my thumb by forcing it
out of its socket to make it appear
longer oh my god
he has a regular thumb the picture of
that thumb is when it's just flapping
hanging out that's disgusting
but is it hot ladies is a long thumb
like that hot
it's not hot
right you think it's hot you like a long
thumb what do you like about a long
thumb ma'am is it turning do you like
that
no she now don't just don't she just
went yeah
she's like they're talking to me and i'm
embarrassed
you just yelled like it was girls gone
wild in reuters you know what i give you
you know what i give you a five and a
half inch thumbs down
[Laughter]
thumbs up okay yeah i don't know i mean
i i could do that my thumb goes like
this and then it snaps back i think i
could do something like that yeah oh you
know what speaking of weird body not
weird but like
a bit larger than normal body stuff okay
the guest tomorrow night right you can
kind of say now uh the special surprise
guests from our hey babe universe will
be the woman with the world's biggest
mouth yes yes and if you come to the
show tomorrow you can bring an item
that's been sanitized and you can try to
fit it in her mouth swear to god she's
told us that she's cool with that she
can put anything in her mouth she did
say she's going to try to put the couch
in her mouth yes
she is yeah if she does get the couch in
our mouth we're not giving it away
but i think that's even better
that's going to be big i can't even see
the people in the back i can't see the
people in the back wow is it scary back
there
like look behind you you could be killed
by a murderer coming from the woods any
second no not a murderer but we are in
the middle of pennsylvania there could
be a bear or a deer with rabies or
something there's so many ways you can
get back there
what do you want to eat after this you
want to go to wawa what do you want to
do i
love wawa dude you want to go i love
wawa let's go i grew up going to wawa
doesn't wanwa send you merch didn't they
send you yeah they sent me a whole bunch
because i was like that's how we know
we're we're not eating right when wah
wah
we should be time to clean up the diet
yeah no i used to drive down to the
jersey shore like with my mom when we
were kids and we'd always always go to
wawa what shout out your mom shout out
my mom shout out wawa shout out fresh
bread at reasonable prices should we
bring our moms tomorrow should our moms
also be the special guest let's bring
our moms my mom is in hershey
pennsylvania right now because she just
texted me saying is that near here
i can't be far is that like
an hour it's an hour when you get your
mom i'll bring my mom
oh i can't i don't i mean
why not let's have our moms up here well
i know that she just told me she's
staying in a hotel with my nieces
because they're going to hershey park
hersheypark's a lot of fun you ever go
to park uh
yes
once
what happened um
no it was cool it was this weird thing
actually so it was like in october and
it was that thing where you can go like
at five o'clock it opens it like
whatever it is and it's like only like
20 bucks yes and i went on a night when
nobody was there i didn't wait on
anything and i went on seven roller
coasters in a row and i i got violently
like ill i just said i told you before i
threw up on a roller coaster it was that
yeah hershey park is my favorite
amusement park in the country i love it
my mother would take me there all the
time we would go there she would take me
you know single mom we would go we'd
take the train down there i love hershey
park i was there one summer and they
experimented for this for literally
three days because kids were vomiting
left and right when you take the hershey
chocolate world ride when you first walk
into the park they had at the end of
that ride for kids under 10. a water
fountain that was chocolate milk that
you could press a button and it would
you could stay there for as long as you
wanted and me along with thousands of
other children stayed there for way too
long and vomited all over the park and
they shut it down after three days
that's a true 100 fact that i was a part
of history porn
yeah
oh my god yeah i um yeah i i love i love
hershey park i love you can i tell you
this is a little bit of a weird story
why we got the channel it just jogged my
memory and it's really freaking well i
got news for you this is hey babe after
dark so we can get weird okay so
[Applause]
one time actually you know who i did go
to in pennsylvania a lot uh sesame is
langhorne pennsylvania by here
we're close to that sesame place have
you been there love sesame place gonna
take the kids yeah they got that uh lazy
river sure
a lot of piss a lot of piss pissed in
that no no there's a lot of piss in that
i'd imagine yeah you can't go in that i
read a study they tested the water
there's like hundreds of gallons of piss
in it really what do you expect you
throw a kid in a river just goes round
and round all day long but what do you
expect anything i mean you know you go
in the ocean it's it's ocean is just
fish piss yeah i understand that you
know there's a bug going on i know it
keeps landing on me should we give away
this tomorrow tuition yeah we'll give
this away yeah we'll give away the sign
well i don't know why we're telling you
it's just something for you to get
jealous over but anybody coming to the
show tomorrow anybody oh wow okay we got
a few people coming the show tomorrow
all right very good very good so i'm i'm
in six flags in general don't hit me in
jackson new jersey
and uh i was like oh jackson new jersey
is that near here
everything everything's just a little
bit so this is very weird so i was with
friends we were like i want to say like
not lovers friends no we yeah we had a
bunch of friends and i was probably like
in my early teens maybe like 13. and we
went for the day and we were online and
this girl around our age
walks up to
me and a couple of my friends and we're
online she goes and she's like laughing
and giggling and she goes excuse me
because can i ask you guys something my
friends dared me to come over and ask
are you the impractical jokers no
13 years old
this is weird it takes a weird left turn
at albuquerque
so she says so will i love it okay and
she goes you know when you this is
i don't know this person this girl she
goes you know when you guys like
jericho
[Music]
and i was like what is about to
man like we were online for like the
great american screen machine yeah and
she approaches giggling she goes i'm
sorry i i i
it's a dare but you know when you guys
you're coming and we were like okay
and she's like this is what she said
where do you like
finnish
is it in like
buckets
and then that threw me
because i was like
is something wrong with me
yeah
and i didn't want to
in that moment i couldn't reconcile
whether i i should have always been
ejaculating bucket amounts into a bucket
or she doesn't know what she's talking
about and so i looked this girl dead in
the eye 13 year old a 13 year old i go
yeah buckets yeah
yeah and then she went back and told her
friends and like the rest of the day
they just thought i was a guy who
ejaculated 128 ounces into buckets
that's it yeah she's now on point hub
ruined her life
i go into the belly button fyi
just leave it there but what she left an
impression on and indelible it's 31
years later i'm talking about it on a
tuesday night in pennsylvania she's a
special guest
[Laughter]
well this may seem merely unappealing
2014 study suggested that urine can
actually combine with the chlorine
disinfectant in swimming pool water to
make potentially harmful chemicals
researchers recommend that all swimmers
avoid urinating in swimming pools to
prevent these chemicals from forming
that sounds like somebody like
somebody's mom made that up
what's that on google i recently read
this because i was gonna join a public
pool near my house right and so i was
like is this gonna be safe for me and so
i i found out that you know when you're
in a pool
and you really smell chlorine a lot and
you think i think at least that oh they
loaded this thing up with chlorine
that's good
it's bad
why when you really really smell
chlorine it's a combination of it
activating when mixing with a large
copious amount of urine really so when
you smell the chlorine the whole time
and you thought that there was extra
chlorine there's actually actually urine
now what you've been just swimming in
urine what if you [ __ ] in the pool what
does the chlorine smell like i don't
know did that happen to you happened to
me i didn't [ __ ]
for somebody [ __ ]
there was [ __ ] floating around and it
was a while before it was identified
yeah and we all we all jumped out except
for two kids who volunteered to get the
[ __ ]
they got a plastic bag and threw on
goggles and they swam down and they
bagged the [ __ ] in about the four foot
area now either they either they [ __ ] at
the same time or one of them
grab the other one [ __ ] no nobody knows
who this [ __ ] was from but it had to be
one of those two no
everybody was in the pool the pool got
cleared oh you're saying that [ __ ]
yeah yeah but i wouldn't pick it up if
it was my [ __ ] it was my [ __ ] i would be
the that would be the last thing i do i
don't want people to know it's my [ __ ]
so therefore i would go say i'm going to
get it to deflect me people think that
i'm the one who actually [ __ ] in the
pool oh
you're saying like a strategy
if you [ __ ] there's no way you're going
to volunteer to get the [ __ ]
yes so then you're making people believe
it's not you when you did [ __ ] yes
yes
okay you know because it's right in
front of you you never see the things
that are right in front of you yeah but
also also
i would never
go diving for someone else's [ __ ] you
want to go [ __ ] diving
[Laughter]
where's the weirdest place you ever had
to emergency [ __ ]
um i didn't have to emergency do this
but i did one time we were at my friend
brian's house party and for no reason
whatsoever i was 16 years old i [ __ ] in
his hamper
oh that's wrong bro this was very wrong
bro so this was a time when there were
no group chats yet so we got a three-way
call on a landline it was me brian and
the two two brothers uh two friends who
are brothers ian and sean and he said i
know one of you three [ __ ] in the hamper
he said because my mom went to go do the
a full load of laundry and washed our
clothes with [ __ ] in it so i know it was
one of you three so which one was it and
it was me it was like genuinely me but
at the time my that brian's dad was
dating my mother they were in a
relationship he was a mole santa
well no that was gary oh gary gary his
mom dated him all santa yes
so they so so i didn't want to cop to it
because i i didn't want my mom i didn't
want my mom to like it sure caused like
a fight yeah but he would be like you
know
you sound [ __ ] in my clothes well yeah
so but i so i i just i just told my mom
that i was like hey like i [ __ ] i [ __ ]
in the hamper
because it was he lived in the hat like
you know that guy lived in the house it
was his father's house what did you
think the outcome would be
to [ __ ] when i sat in the hamper yeah
like there had to be
consequences
you can't just [ __ ] in someone's hamper
and just skip away it was one of those
things where i genuinely wasn't i wasn't
thinking at all i had to [ __ ] and i
thought it'd be funny to [ __ ] in the
hamper
and the bathroom wasn't occupied you
know what i'm saying yeah it's not like
it was a long line i watched someone
[ __ ] in someone's tank
like that what they call it they call it
an upper decker
have you heard of this
was when you get [ __ ] on the top of the
rim and the
david tell us a joke he says you tony
hawked it
where it's on that i think
deco is when you open like the tank
on top of the bowl and then you [ __ ] in
there and close the tank again i never
even thought about doing that it's
terrible i watched someone do it and the
image is burned in my mind yeah that's
bad because they had to hover
over the bowl
in a way that
what was the first time i had ever seen
anything like that one time my mother
told me she was going to send me to
military school i had been getting in a
lot of trouble to begin with but
my uh
toilet our toilet family toilet was
broken so i had to really use the
bathroom and i didn't want to [ __ ] in
the sink again so what i said was is i
said i'm going to [ __ ] i i swear to god
i placed a i placed down paper towels
and a plastic bag and i [ __ ] into a
plastic bag and then tied it up and put
the paper towels over it and i was gonna
go throw it out in the garbage but my
landline rang and my basketball coach
was there to pick me up we had a game in
like an hour so i ran down the stairs
with my basketball gear and left the
[ __ ] on a paper towel tied up in a
plastic bag outside of the toilet and
then when i got home that night my
mother said i'm sending you to military
school
she said you [ __ ] in a bag like the dog
and left it outside the toilet what is
wrong with you i would have been like uh
excuse me i'm training for military
school yeah
so you think when i'm out in the [ __ ]
that's what i have to do yeah i would
have got lippy with her in that moment
yeah so that that's the only is it crazy
we have an audience mike to ask
if anyone has like a crazy place where
they've [ __ ] [ __ ] before i'd like to do
that this is by the way this is what we
do on hey babe every week is we don't
start out with a plan and sometimes
you're doing the show for 400 live
audience and it just takes a [ __ ] turn
and that's just
and that's what's happening and we like
to embrace that so there's anybody who
has a good [ __ ] story
oh wow hands went up
a woman we could do it i mean why not
pimpy's right there
this guy i can't believe zach with no k
doesn't have a good [ __ ] story yeah i
mean yeah
yeah i'm sure yeah you you've [ __ ] in
your hand and throwing it
throwing up
who's got a mic mike you got the mic
pimp does that work
oh you got to turn them on
yeah you're not on yet
give it up for the homeless pimp
this guy has a good [ __ ] story he said
hi hi what's your name so you have a
good what's your name my name is vanessa
hi vanessa hi vanessa
this is like your shitter's anonymous
stand up
vanessa say hi my name is vanessa and
this is my [ __ ] story yeah and call
yourself yeah and say
i'm the [ __ ] queen
hi my name's vanessa this is my [ __ ]
story
hi vanessa [ __ ] queen
hi vanessa
so i was living with my boyfriend at the
time and i had previously clogged his
toilet to the point where his
grandfather was so talking to them right
now
put the mic right up there
you had previously clogged his toilet
previously clogged this toilet so bad
that his 80 year old grandfather had to
get in there with the snake and like
really rip it out so i was traumatized
fast forward like a month later and i
had to [ __ ] so
and everyone was home and i was i did
cross through the living room to get to
the bathroom and there was no way i was
going to let them know that i was taking
a [ __ ] so
but please tell the 400 000 listeners
yeah
so i took a shoe box in the bedroom
i [ __ ] in the shoe box
put the shoe box in a bag and walked it
outside and put it in the garbage and it
got picked up
i'm
[Applause]
can i can i can i just pitch something
right now can i pitch something right
now stay right there we've never had a
guest on hey babe can she be the first
guest on ebay yes
[Applause]
this is vanessa the [ __ ] queen we gotta
talk to her
all hail vanessa the [ __ ] queen
[ __ ] queen
who knew our first guest
the puss
vanessa who just told us she [ __ ] in a
shoebox
welcome vanessa
how how you doing honey nice to meet you
still have you mike where's your mind i
got your phone all right
homeless pimp's got the phone hello i
have sit with us by the way i smell a
brewing romance between homeless pimp
and the [ __ ] queen
call me
whoa
homeless pimps on edibles he's his
reactions are delayed enough i know he's
taking inedible in the back
you can share with me what do you think
single little little known fact about
homeless people unfortunately you are
single no i mean fortunately no wait
no i have a boyfriend but i mean
who cares
he wasn't cool enough to come here so
exactly oh really
oh dump him like a shit-filled shoebox
babe amen
[Applause]
here's okay couple things um you what
i'm confused about
we all heard the story
real quick
i would assume you're from philadelphia
boxes yeah okay congratulations
yep
so you didn't want to
but you you still
did the exact same thing
as [ __ ] you still [ __ ] [ __ ] came out
of you in a room
it's just that you walked it out the
door
instead of down the pipes but until
today no one knew that because there was
no flush there was no flush what about
the smell traipsing through the house
well i did wait a couple minutes you
know and then and i febreze you got it
febreze if you don't febreze and you're
disassembling you walked out of the back
room in front of a family full of people
with a shoe box smelling like a meadow
don't you think the febreze is a dead
giveaway it was pumpkin spice for
starters okay now i'm hungry i'm sorry
it's not unusual for me to smell like
pumpkin spice so yes yeah but you walk
in and then when you walk back by the
way where were you going with a bag and
a box like did they nobody looked at you
and was like yeah where is she going
were you like oh i got new sneakers so i
put the shoe box in it was like a
birthday bag or something and then i was
just like taking out the trash and just
looked it up you were taking out a
shoebox-sized bag of trash i was in your
boyfriend's home yep
and you don't think ex-boyfriend you
don't think that everybody there had a
side conversation that was like did you
smell the abundance of pumpkin spice
when she walked out of the basement if
they did they were nice enough to not
say anything wow was it leaving
halloween
no yeah so they knew you shouldn't
pumpkin
[Laughter]
to do a human function in the proper
place and flush it in front of six
people but you're singing
to the world
it's my [ __ ]
how did you wait
what about like how do you know that
like there was an empty where were the
shoes that were in that box they still
were like where the hell is my jordan
shoebox
so it was tom's shout out toms um it's a
tom shoebox
they're very into you know biodegradable
and nature stuff so yeah they are big
time so i was kind of giving back to you
i should i could have buried it or
something and thinking back like i wish
i'd done something cooler with it
this [ __ ] is bananas h-e-y-b-a-b-e
this [ __ ] is h-e-y-b-a-d
this [ __ ] in a shoe box
pumpkin spice
did you did you should be okay
what room were you in so i was in the
back bedroom when all this occurred and
i had to walk up a hallway just in the
living room and then right out like the
door off the kitchen was it a spare
bedroom was it his bedroom it was his
bedroom we were living together at the
time okay
get him on the phone i don't know if i
had his number i would
because he's a dirtbag
wow
says the woman who's [ __ ] in a box in
his room
touche
i love it
let me tell you about this guy he was a
real low down dirty fella
what are the chances she's telling us
while she's [ __ ] and hovering did
you hover
how did you do it oh good question how'd
you know you're going to hit the target
yourself very tastefully okay you know
you put the box on the bed no no no you
don't get to call this that's a very
tasteful way to do it if anybody could
do a taste release the [ __ ] queen thank
you
i just put it on the edge of the bed
like where like the corner oh my god you
didn't put it on the [ __ ] floor
what have you got it on the comforter
wait you you why put it that high
did you sit did your ass touch box i was
thinking it was a hover i was thinking
it was a hover
so you use the edge of the box like a
[ __ ] toilet seat so i don't sit on
toilet seats like at least ever because
it's disgusting yeah um
is okay vanessa there is no way you're
vaccinated oh god i know you're not
you you are you should work for the
public health you should you would be
the perfect girl hey guys even i got
vaccinated and i [ __ ] in boxes
you clearly have sad
dr fauci needs you
you clearly have sat with this story for
years and made it okay in your mind in
your mind
[Applause]
did you ever hear this story ever in
your life you knew this story so this
has been circulating around
for a long time have you ever [ __ ] in a
box
interesting
okay so please go ahead um so i just
hovered over the corner like on the on
the edge
got it done um i
i took an old t-shirt
[Applause]
stop it's very tasteful
it's very tasty
she could have used something like
toilet paper but she didn't i didn't
have she wanted to keep it on the up and
up guys give it up for salvagano's
calves please great cats
and his hairless legs he's like a sphynx
cat
so the t-shirt went in the box as well
so did he does he know you did this oh
yeah oh okay okay he knows so i remember
remember how in the in the first couple
of months of the podcast we sent [ __ ] in
a box to bad friends yes who did we send
vanessa [ __ ] in a box too what podcast
oh my god who do we send it to
tim dillon's podcast
the tim dillon would you would you be
willing to send your [ __ ] to tim dillon
it would be my honor
vanessa
homeless pimp if you don't take this
girl out on a date you're fired
i don't know who
in the world could top that [ __ ] story
you know i don't know if we're gonna
have an hour of [ __ ] stories but after
that just happened i say why not i don't
i don't know forget the show i don't
know who's gonna be a better guest than
her i know we could literally have the
ex-president on what did you think the
family of the boyfriend that you were
living with would think of you if let's
just say you went to the bathroom like a
normal person
why were you so afraid of that
um i don't think i was afraid i was just
so
embarrassed at the time because this
poor 80 year old man had to get on his
knees and like dig for my [ __ ] out of a
toilet and i was trying to spare them i
think oh because of the previous blowout
because of the preaching because you
were so worried about that
you had clogging ptsd yes well vanessa i
then it bears to this question is that
the only time you've [ __ ] in a box that
is the only time i've ever [ __ ] in a box
but i'm there's a bot
and it's vanessa's
i did about two years ago had to
had to go when i was at the beach okay
so we dug a hole
we pooped in the hole and we buried it
up so can i ask you a question
vanessa do you have a home to live in
where do you live
if you're homeless can you she could
sleep on the couch tonight yeah yeah
yeah
i have a home yes well it doesn't sound
like it
you're [ __ ] in halls
i just live on the edge what do you do
yeah
we know so i work for a company that
manages foreclosed homes for banks so we
kick people out of their houses
my god oh my god you are the funniest
person i've ever met
you kick you kick people out of their
homes for a living
i mean they kick themselves
their
out
okay i'm sorry
this school of hot knocks from the [ __ ]
queen herself
they kicked themselves i love it
i love that
definitely a republican
not that's good or bad it's just that
that's a republican stance they do kick
themselves out i guess 100
wow well vanessa i mean god bless we got
some new merch ideas yeah
vanessa's box
it's not what you think it is i'll buy
it
you're give it give it up for vanessa
everybody holy [ __ ] vanessa first aid
guest ever was a real doozy
you're the best it was amazing to meet
you i love you i actually love you
i mean what a great beautiful person
beautiful smile
amazing she has everything going for her
except that she's just
shits in boxes and kicks people out of
her house there's a box we can get if
she you know if anybody has a box if she
needs to go he's an a-plus plus
i love tar that was a great first hey
baby yes i i know and i don't
even can someone if you think we move on
from yeah who are you gonna get yeah you
beat the [ __ ] queen no no
listen you know me you know i love hello
fresh babes you know sally babes loves
hello fresh that's why he's not on this
ad because he's out there eating hello
fresh that's what it is hello fresh
recipes they're out they got the fall
recipes coming at you me i've been using
hellofresh i've spoken about this on
this podcast on my other podcast christy
chaos we've been speaking about
hellofresh always and i'm telling you
hellofresh has changed me and sally
babe's life like legitimately me and sal
all we do is talk about um babes guys
and girls and hello fresh we've made all
types of different meals they got family
friendly meals they got pumpkin cinnamon
rolls are you out of your [ __ ] mind
they have pumpkin cinnamon rolls and
they are fantastic
okay and this year following them going
as a pumpkin cinnamon roll
friendsgiving ready sides because you
know we're about to get fat dude i lost
a few pounds and i'm gonna gain them all
back because it is fall season and i'm
ready to face pumpkin spice
um
listen hello fresh is 30 cheaper than
shopping at grocery stores okay let me
put that into
so you
money's tight right now in this country
because they want to stop the stimula
checks so now 30 percent cheaper at
grocery stores saving you money and it's
better food and it's healthier and
you're going to get an even better
discount when you go through us if you
go to hellofresh.com
slash hey babe 14 and use the code hey
babe 14 you're going to get 14 free
meals including free shipping so that's
what i say with hello freshers what what
have you got to lose at the very least
you're going to get 14 free meals if you
just go to hellofresh.com hey babe14 and
use the code haybay14 including the free
shipping do it hellofresh america's
number one meal kit
you know in brooklyn what we say all the
time we say that's mint and what i want
to tell you is mint right now is mint
mobile ryan reynolds phone company ryan
reynolds one of the hottest guys on the
planet even my dad said he'd hook up
with ryan reynolds that's how hot he was
that's how audience and this phone
company the phone plan mint mobile what
it offers is premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month so
these cell phone companies are getting
going out there and causing
they're way too much money they're way
too much money half the time the phone's
in the dead zone it doesn't work but
mint mobile for 15
a month
fifteen dollars a month they're going to
give you premium wireless cell service
by cutting out the real retail stores
there's no crazy overhead costs that get
passed down to you in the form of some
mystery fee so that's how they get you
that's the secret sauces they're not
going to the retail stores that's why we
pay all this money at these other phone
companies because of the stores mint
mobile doesn't do a store they sell
everything writer ryan reynolds [ __ ]
so mint mobile they offer premium
wireless for just 15 bucks a month all
plans come with unlimited talk and text
plus high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network you use your
own phone with any mint mobile plan and
keep your same phone number along with
all your existing contacts if you're not
100 satisfied mint mobile has you
covered with their 7 day back money
guarantee switch to mint mobile right
now and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 a month to get your
new wireless plan for just 15 bucks a
month and get the plan shipped to your
door for free go to mintmobile.com
a babe that's mint mobile.com slash hey
babe cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks
a month at
mintmobile.com and she is the woman with
the world's biggest mouth
given up
for this world's big escape
[Applause]
[Music]
look at that now guinness book
guinness book record holder female with
the world's biggest mouth world's
biggest mouth uh should we sit here in
the middle yeah let's sit in the middle
would you i was gonna say again stan
so hi samantha so first of all where are
you from hi i'm from stanford
connecticut okay shout out stanford
connecticut yeah okay here could you sit
in the middle yeah
and you were in the back green room with
us and i walked up to you and i said i
have a million questions and i'm gonna
wait until i get onto the stage when did
you know when did you know you had a big
mouth
since i could look in the mirror pretty
much yeah now does anybody else in your
family have a big mouth or is it just
you it's just me so i have i have family
members with big smiles
but
yeah i don't know something got lost
yeah so that just is uh just
it's just it's just it's like no
you don't have any
yeah there's no addition no acceleration
so you don't have like a great aunt no
okay not that i know of okay um yeah it
was just a natural phenomenon you know
and you know to be honest sitting here
very close to it does feel it's it feels
like it's it's nice it's a not it you
know a very pretty girl but it does feel
a little bit like um there's a
gravitational pull in your mouth
i feel
like it's it's got a little bit of its
own energy because you're looking at me
but it's like a black hole don't you
feel a little bit oh god yeah whoa
whoa
i stand right into the mouth of the
velvet of her of you yeah i don't know i
wasn't expecting you to do that when you
open i've never been that close to
greatness before could you imagine could
you imagine like your first day as a
dentist and she's your first patient
right she says open up you're like no
you're probably a dentist's dream oh my
god
i mean they could probably just get in
there without even any trying to fight
over me i have dentists that reach out
and ask if they can fly me to their
dentist office like in florida like all
around i want to work on you you're
royalty but it's a lot of work you're
like you're an extra worker you're like
an only fans for dentists
that your teeth are exceptional
beautiful teeth it would be it would be
a just a curse if you had the world's
biggest mouth but the most jacked up
teeth well i had an underbite when i was
little okay so yeah there's been no
surgical intervention there's been no
surgical intervention now nice yeah on
that journal
yeah
i just have so many one of you one for
one yes yes so my question is when you
were a kid let's say you're in third
fourth grade where like you know people
like would they throw things in your
mouth would they yeah what what would
what would the kind of kids like because
i would imagine if you were in my class
i would say you know we gotta like you
know i tried to put number two pencils
in you know yeah throw things in the
mouth or if i if i was smoking a
cigarette in high school my mom's gonna
say oh [ __ ] you know throw it yeah you
know yeah totally yeah if you ever get
pulled over by the cops you just put
every single thing in the car yeah i
just shove it all in your mouth
registration please
reach down in did they celebrate you in
in in grammar school did you did you
have a hard time no no no no no no no no
no no it was a rough it was a rough
growing at it you know yeah but what did
people what would the kids tease you
about like what anybody tried to put
anything in your mouth or well it was a
lot of like big mouth bass like people
threw water on me because they said i
was a fish and i should get back in the
ocean because like
well if you do that
you're doing an amazing fish impression
i don't think of a i don't think of uh
of a fish is having a big mouth no i
don't either
i think of their cheeks actually going
in and having a small mouth like now
what now what do you because this is the
kid who we originally talked about this
is the boy with the world's biggest
mouth have you ever met him so turns out
he's 16.
and he like lives in minneapolis so i
felt weird being like like messaging
like an underage kid being like you want
to do some health stuff together
hey you want to shove some stuff in our
mouths together so i felt a little weird
but um i would let you know i think that
would be some good content yes some good
yeah are you guys gonna have eventually
when he's legal 18 when he's legal well
i even said you know i'm like hey if
your mom wants you know guardian yoshi
hang out
oh my god yeah yeah he's like okay
yeah because it's interesting
and so you actually though have the word
you have the guinness
book of world records for the female
biggest
yes but technically
i don't know if you met my ex
okay
um like it wasn't a sexual joke it was
like she has a big mouth it was like
she's mouthing all right let's all just
forget that one yeah edit that out um
but it was you know i have a wider mouth
technically 14 and a half centimeters
wow wide now how much is that in inches
it's like 80
so did you call them or did they hear
about you and contact you how does word
get out about it so i say it was the
tick tock children of america okay you
know it was really my tick tockers if
anyone's a tick tocker out here so
you're newly crowned new within two
weeks oh do you know who whose crown you
took
i don't know some
amateur yeah
yeah if you're watching and we know that
you are yeah
yeah
no more you imagine having the world's
second biggest mouth i know i mean
that's such a downer you got to walk
around be like you see this it's
progressive right it's not the biggest
runner up yeah what about eating
competitions like would would you be
good in like a hot dog like could you
take down joey chestnut well so i've
actually dueted some of his videos and
obviously i can't eat as much as he can
but i can eat pretty fast so like i
would say like i would love to go up to
him like a who can eat a hot dog the
fastest like one hot dog yeah you know
what i mean yeah because you yeah
because i mean i would think you could
well i can shove it shove it down there
pretty get it right down yeah yeah yeah
right
well let's just let's just all think it
together and not say anything the fan
wants to know yeah
this is a pg show hey my daughter's here
come up here
in my mouth she's asking
yes please just shut up when you stretch
out your mouth does it hurt
yeah
it does not hurt no it's like my muscles
in my face are jacked yeah
like yeah you're jacked overall jacked
yeah yeah you know
gotta watch out on the streets how do
they measure the mouth
caliper oh there's a video there's a
video somewhere where they're like it's
like a digital it's like a construction
so you didn't know when they came to you
if you were gonna beat the person
it was a thing they did but they might
have measured you and been like sorry
you didn't make it totally oh so were
you nervous
a little but i was you wanted the title
right i mean i felt pretty good i felt
pretty good going in and you had to just
expand your mouth as much as you can
yeah you have to do it five times in a
row by a dentist by like a certified
professional
and the average of the five times and
you have to do obviously
top to bottom and
side to side and i just came to your
house and did that no we had to go to a
dentist's office i had to do a whole
thing we had to get witnesses we had to
get witness statements we had to get i
had to get blood work i had to get i had
to prove i'm not on any medication that
would make my mouth stretch
like it's crazy it's very strict it's so
interesting do you have like a plaque or
something i do i should have brought it
i should have brought it yeah so what's
next for you what's next for the for the
mouth
well um you know movies are we doing
movies or it's like yeah maybe like a
scary movie like you want to do that i
would you know i you know i do like to
do some if you're on my tech talk i do
like to do some some jokes once in a
while
oh yeah yeah um you said you sing right
yeah you sing
can you sing a little bit
yeah anybody want to hear sam saying can
you sing um
would you like to sing the national
anthem oh can you sing uh big mouths by
morrissey
what's the song you like to sing um
i don't know anyone else anyone get a
song like a big mouth what's like a
steven tyler well you know
oh oh he's got a big [ __ ] mouth
yeah yeah
right
yeah i see a
little man
you know what i mean yeah
no no
you start you teased us i want to hear
you belt it out what can we what song is
good yeah how about what do you know
what do you know like a nice ballad what
about my name show you the world oh i
gotta show you the world do you know
that one i don't know
i don't know yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
whatever you want
let it go
let it go
can't hold it back anymore
let it go
[Music]
do you think that this oh speaking of
singing cargo trades coming through
that's it there we go this [ __ ] is
bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e this [ __ ] is bananas hd
this [ __ ] is bananas h-e-y-b-a-b-e
this [ __ ] is bananas h-e-y-b-a-b-e
we can stop now but it's gonna go by for
another three minutes yeah
this is good
this is good six o'clock shows are good
yeah this is six o'clock 100 degrees
that's all i'm doing for that's what it
is
yeah that's all i ever want to do from
now yeah
do you think you could fit the train in
your mouth probably so i go on the trail
tracks and see
what are you gonna do one day when your
jaw breaks accidentally never i will
never break my jaw i'm a professional
you know i train i stretch do you do
mouth and now you have the title do you
like keeping yourself insurance yeah i
mean she's injured
no you're not oh okay i said that um do
you ever worry about this 16 year old
[ __ ] from minnesota taking your title
yeah this little [ __ ] what is this
little bitch's name
isaac [ __ ]
isaac isaac if you're watching you know
and we know isaac's watching right now
because you got someone gunned for can
your mouth grow any further
can you i don't know i feel like maybe
my mouth can get stronger like maybe you
know
yeah you know i could hold more okay i
don't know
and you know the opportunities are
endless true you feel and you you're
proud of it you're proud
yeah like you know embrace what makes
you different you know embrace what
makes sense
right [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
absolutely
okay well speaking of that so you've
brought something i brought some tricks
to put into your mouth so we'd like to
see that we thought for the live babe
babe she could put some tricks in her
mouth yep um so i brought a little you
know a couple tricks for you guys i
figured i don't know if you guys want to
participate and be involved in the
activities i'm trying to put something
in my mouth yeah it would be the first
time today yeah
all right so mike one of my classics is
some donuts okay um but i also have you
know maybe we start out we warm up with
a lemon
you want to put a lemon in our yeah yeah
oh yeah we could try that oh i'm not
gonna
okay
okay all right so so
so are we doing it sideways no no right
in right now like this long ways
holy holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
no i'm gonna charge i'm seriously gonna
try this for you okay
i might could i can i oh my god
it's the whole thing's in her mouth holy
[ __ ]
uh is there anything realizing by the
way by even just trying to do this
there's no way i could be gay is it
is there any scenario where this gets
lodged and literally blocks my past no
it legitimately
i know the heimlich it legitimately
hurts my jaw to even try to do this just
try to open your mouth as you've never
tried
it it hurts
wow well's actually getting in there
that's great
wow
[Music]
oh my god that's pretty good
that's great
i am very important [ __ ] you isaac yes
that was really impressive all right
okay so that's a lot all right so the
next step wow should we just put yeah
okay here you go
an apple
all right let's get an apple on now all
right ready yeah
oh my god the way you do it is like it's
oh my god be careful with yourself
no there's no give on the apple hi the
lemon had a little give there's no give
on this you know apples
you know apples
how many of you have heard of an apple
how many of you want to shout
corrections at me about apples
i can't do it
it hurts my jaw all right
it really does hurt how about this
okay okay so we have a bag of carrots
what is this
um so
14 and a half centimeters wide and about
like eight centimeters top to bottom
why don't we do this why don't we do
this yeah you
why don't we why don't we
to see who's when we make a little
competition to see who's gonna win the
couch why don't we get three people up
what do you think three yeah i think
three let's get three people up here
that will pick
um i most likely gonna be three white
people um because that's
because i you know wait way to be
diverse on our crowd i thought we had a
lot of diverse let's get an asian up
here too if we have one
i mean
why don't we and then whoever can fit
the most things in their mouth wins the
couch
yeah we do do we have marshmallows we
have a whole thing of marshmallows okay
how about this whoever can fit the most
marshmallows okay
in their mouth let's pick let me ask you
whoever's raising your hand you have a
way to get the couch home with you
tonight i don't know because
we're leaving
how about this you want to do this yeah
yeah okay yeah okay how about this
here's what we're going to do hold on
hold on
okay here's what we're gonna do no
samantha you're on stage here's what we
want to do to make it fair and it's
listen it's 20 21.
so we are going to
call up
one man
which we'll pick as what man well let's
see everybody anybody who any guy is
getting out of the champion i mean what
about this guy yeah i love it dead
center you get up you already got the
shirt that says champion on it champion
you get up here one woman
sal picked a woman who do we think as a
woman
who really thinks she needs a couch but
who believes you could win who believes
you you need it and she's gone
come on one man one woman
[Applause]
and then to only make it fair in 2021
one transgender tt jerry
[Applause]
t
t t t t t
[Applause]
how are my lovely ladies doing today
gentlemen too my handsome guys how you
doing tonight yes
oh my god all right i am so hot
oh my god and looking at all these
handsome dudes in here oh my god i'm
getting hotter guys
all right let's go let's do this tj how
are we going to do it
does everyone know who jerry is but
i know a lot of you do anyone here does
not know who our beloved tt is
you all know who tv is actually
right on [ __ ] all right you need no
introduction so why don't we do it
because because i've already given you
my couch from home
so what what do how about this instead
of tt instead of tt having an
opportunity to do it why don't we just
do man one of these two will win okay
because if t tt's got a couch but tv is
still doing not only that is if i do it
i'm taking all these in my mouth
how about that listen when tc sees white
balls they go in her mouth so
do you think
do it too just because if she wins then
she can designate the only problem is i
just don't want tt to come on the front
row
that's the
okay
congratulations anybody looking for a
date with tt you're lucky
you don't have enough for everybody okay
how many can you put in your mouth
she could put 15 in her mouth how much
are in a package we might have enough we
might have enough okay let's try okay
okay are you guys ready for this right
now
why don't you go last okay
just in case okay okay all right you
ready let's stick but stay with us all
right so how we're gonna start this is
samantha's gonna go first yeah right
samantha's going to put well samantha
already knows she can put 15 in her
mouth so why would we have her do th you
know what i mean
at the end okay yeah yeah yeah yeah all
right we got a fact check yeah you know
what we
saying samantha you're a liar prove it
okay
i mean i mean wait a minute but this
guy's kind of big
i think he could put a lot of
marshmallows in his mouth he might be
able to but no but
it's not about his stomach it's about
your mouth
okay samantha's gonna go put so samantha
says she could put you want to lead off
and do a demonstration
what to do we're going to counter no no
no this is these are it's really about
you're going to put 15 in your mouth and
then what's your name sir i'm jay jay
jay and what your name is hannah jay and
hannah are going to whoever can put more
marshmallows in their mouth is going to
win this couch
that's what they're going to win
okay pip can you remind us if someone
can mine has to sign it remind us and we
will sign it we'll sign the couch still
if you want to okay so you ready we're
going to get out okay do either one of
you have pickup trucks or a way to get
this couch out of here oh you both do
it's roy's from pennsylvania okay
yeah they're like yeah it's fine yeah
okay so you ready okay so this is one
let's go
one one oh my god you tuck it to the
side
she talks about it wow she tucks it tt
knows a thing or two about time don't do
it don't do it sam
let me do it
three
oh
four
five
six oh my god lord have mercy
seven
eight
[Laughter]
you sound like the count from sesame
street
nine
[Applause]
oh my god all right oh my god and then
it comes no it's just one it was just
one spit into a cup
okay so now round of applause for sam
please
thank you
she's gonna put the audience in her
mouth after the show so
now let's go let's should we go jay or
hannah first why are we doing one for
one
what do you mean
at the same time one two oh why don't we
go at the same time because we're about
equal right
two bags of okay yeah
you can take it you get it back here
that's your bag that's your bag we'll
face it hey come up here hannah jay so
he's saying the seal's been broken don't
worry about it we'll do we'll do uh
simultaneously uh one by one
this is whoever gets more marshmallows
in their mouth wins the signed couch
that sal and i have been farting into
for the past two days
runner up runner-up can take the
backdrop and runner-up will take the
backdrop fair enough yeah fair enough
yes you got it but both of you get a
night with tt yeah
all right here we go hannah jay you
ready ready three two one you don't have
to rush here's the first one one
you're gonna do it together so
we have two for those listening we have
two we have three marshmallows in each
of their mouths okay we have four if
you're listening at home this is what
we're doing here on the live hey babe
you're missing out hold on hold on it's
four right now it's four hold on one
second i'm gonna give you a little pep
talk all right cause you're moving to
college and you need the couch and i
know he's bigger than you do not be
intimidated yeah when you think you
can't shove another marshmallow down
your gullet yeah think about how you're
not gonna you're gonna sit on the floor
you're gonna sit on the floor
no you're not you're gonna sit on the
couch aren't you you're gonna stand up
yeah
nothing against you i just feel like
you're the favorite so i'm trying to
make it interesting yo okay don't be
intimidated by him when you think you
can't go anymore you shove [ __ ] down
your throat
because although yes jay is a big man
but he does have a tiny mouth as i'm
looking at it his mouth it looks like a
dog's [ __ ]
it's tight it's like a chihuahua butt
hannah's got seven
go ahead how many is this how many is
this seven this is seven that's number
seven right now they're both
okay don't just want to call this out
five pieces or 90 cows you're going to
show up you're going to show up to
college and be the only person in the
dorm without a without a couch
nine that's nine
i'm actually fully nervous i just feel
like someone's gonna choke i was yeah
because i'm telling you if they start
choking i'll write the stage i don't
know what to do hannah are you the tiger
babe 10
11 your father's here oh
this is what he this is what he pays for
your education for
call the lawyer if we change jokes no no
liability here he's doing pretty good
how many this is 13 11.
but you're equal you're still equal now
no matter what how many is you're equal
so eleven just stop until you can anyone
know what number this is
13 10 11 12 13 thanks guys
here's the thing if it ends in a tie
we're just going to saw the couch in
half
are you swallowing them
relax
now it looks like it was good
okay 13.
come on baby come on you got it
[Music]
how many is this
15. no it's not because she did 15.
there's no way
i think all right 13. okay here we go
13.
come on
oh my god
hannah
you okay you okay
i don't want to force you to do this
listen if you sleep on the floor for
four years you sleep on the floor for
four years
that's thirteen
fourteen
fourteen wait are you going to break
sam's record
okay
shout out marshmallows she's out
you're out all right all right can you
get another one did you do the extra one
you got all right he's already wearing
the shirt
all right jay
round of applause
but give a round of applause to jay and
of course
and hannah wins the backdrop jay
congratulations on the match
you got
it i didn't come here thinking i would
see you regurgitate 16 arsenal
congratulations everybody you did a
great thank you guys great job great job
you keep the marshmallow back too keep
it give us the cup though you cannot
take that cut back
you you don't want the couch you want to
give up your prize
[Applause]
whoever chooses the number will win the
couch
gt jerry's how about that how about that
but i think we already have degrees
let's go
he's already an agreement let's go
come on she needs a couch dad does she
need the couch
[Laughter]
i'm down i'm right here does she need
the couch does she need the couch she
needs the couch dad saying she needs the
couch does she'll get the couch
all right so
you got the champion they made a nice
little deal handy to get the catcher
college jay you'll get the sign we
appreciate you guys yeah we'll sign it
you want it congratulations
yeah
what's up we'll sign in we'll sign it up
we'll stop it out there because we're
gonna give a little name we're gonna
yeah
whatever you want hannah
yeah
thank you guys thank you guys thank you
thank you thank you thank
you wow wow all right oh my god
nice all right well
not one while t what do you mean now
what now i didn't know you were coming
today
me neither until you hop in the car
tt jerry
tt jerry is we love people love tt she
is um she's a blessing she's a blessing
she's uh she's coming to our life she
was going to come on the hey babe show
um a couple of months ago when you
what do you mean oh because she's on
right now
good point they're back the audience is
back just shouting corrections i love it
no we were going to have her when you
were in l.a and we couldn't close
together in the same room i we were
going to have you possibly come and
co-host with me it didn't come to
fruition but you could definitely be the
fill-in host and one of us can't make it
that'd be amazing would you like to do
that yeah yeah and right now by the way
ttt is also right now is a job you're
cleaning houses if anybody needs it
their house is clean i clean houses
hello
and anything else you want me to clean
it's nice to watch the women laugh and
then be like oh no oh my god
like when i like these guys were
hollering at me and throwing kisses at
me i had my back so i had long-ass hair
bigger tighter pants and they're like oh
my god mommy papi no no oh my god you
look so good when i turn around and go
hell no
what the [ __ ]
it happened to me a couple of times
when you say you clean houses and
anything else that you want me to clean
uh what do you mean
call me to clean your house and you know
well
this has been hey babe um
all right
you want me to stage time
or you want to show my jadens
just show you jaden show my change okay
uh
oh yeah we gotta we'll sign the couch
this is jaden number one at 15 years old
that i got about six years ago
people ask me if it's real it is
unfortunately real
uh they asked me if i'm gonna remove it
that wasn't the spirit of the
competition so i keep it on
q tells me in about 20 years it'll look
like morgan freeman
i mean first of all gorgeous legs on sal
right what do you think of those very
much kids guys very nice legs and then
here is the
here is the uh
the 21 year old full color jaden that i
got in the movie that he posed for and
by the way i said oh god i can't believe
i have to do this but i'll do it for
the joke and how much people will
appreciate it i got this [ __ ] tattoo
not one person has ever said a word to
me about it not one person has come to
you on the street and been like i can't
believe you got the full color 21 year
old jaden tattoo but there it is
he's a great kid he's a great kid from a
great family i'm thinking about getting
jada will and willow and having just
like a smith family mount rushmore on my
thigh and how about this maybe maybe
next year on one of the print you'll get
tt jerry tattoo it'll be your belly
button i'm although i might get you i
might we might maybe we make a bet we
may not get to teach
how about how about how about you on our
back you get a ti i get a t-i t-t oh i
would do that i would do that on each
ass cheek okay
guys thank you so much for coming out it
was fun we appreciate you guys thank you
thank you for listening thank you for
commenting thank you for sharing thank
you we started it in the pandemic we
didn't believe that we would have this
many people come out we love you guys so
much thank you really buddy thank you
guys give it up for we appreciate you
guys thank you so much thank you guys
thank you
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
baby
the best